this place is fancy oh they even got
welcome meatballs and by the looks of
things I'm easily the hardest dude in
this camp what's up elbow we bout to
dominate this bitch welcome to the ML
car junior the third elite basketball
camp for future stars give yourselves a
hand for being invited it's obvious this
place is only for well trained athletes
and Grover said we suck I'm a sec I'm
all of these balls I'm gonna serve these
Bulls with a cherry on top
you ready Jay she's ready for lunch they
gotta carve your own prime rib station
why the hoops a down and we're doing
balls there and now introducing former
NBA world champion the legend the best
Vince warmer the league has ever known
the great Jack Haley hologram we go
we'll all right dude let's get high
welcome brethren here you're gonna learn
from the Great's of the old pies plain
time is proposer we can't all be
starters and with our help none of you
will be but at this bitch warmers camp
pitch warmer camp I thought we were ely
behind every hall-of-famer there's a
bitch warmer yelling is hard out enjoy
the camp Jets and remember our model no
shots no stress no shine no sweat
say it with me no shadows no stress no
shine no sweat no shots no stress no
shine no fluent you me no Shawn